on your podcast you play get-to-know-you
sort of exercises ask you a couple
questions yeah because I seem that you
seem to like that you seem to like to be
the one asking the questions I sure do
so far every time tonight I've asked her
a question she's asked me a question
what's that you want to change control
problem okay okay so would you rather
lose your orgasm or your sense of humor
I would say such a humor because I get
great laughs when I have sex
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's an orgasm yeah don't ask them
they're they're degenerate that's a
humor yeah they're not that funny yeah
they're really not can you lose
something you do not okay guys are high
as a kite there's another one yeah I'm
not gonna do better than that first one
okay if you were a wrestler what
what were your move be and what would
your wrestling name be oh my god I don't
know I have no idea I'd be terrible I
would spend I would be ogre wrestling
who spends all my time oiling my body
like I would spend all of the the match
oiling my body before I Conan no no I
mean in the round I'd be in the ring
oiling my body elaborately and dousing
it with rare oils and be oiled by others
and I would never
and then my mood would be they would
squeeze me and I would just go shooting
out of the ring there's oils too rare
yeah exactly my name would just be Conan
cuz you know I can't be anyone else this
is Who I am
no one's gonna wrestle you yeah they
will there are a lot of people that want
to be on that answer yes you can give me
an hour I had an idea I had oh go ahead
go ahead yeah all right if you were a
wrestler I would want you to be big red
okay
it's a lot to live up to that name yeah
you might spicy but you might lose your
flavor a little quick quick I didn't
like this at all what kind of wrestler
it's big red
he's spicy but he'll lose his flavor
quickly that's terrible just accept you
yeah we were wrestlers and you remember
when we were arrested in Mexico City in
charge I forget what my name was
we were looters you were a rooster and I
was the resource was a goddamn baby
every time a comedy writer thinks let's
dress Andy up is something that's a
goddamn thing
yeah I'm cursed I have a toddler's body
I always know my god very strange like
like a brief like check back in 20 years
yeah
[ __ ] check back in ten
you